con altas cercas decenas de policías y
mucho temor los estudiantes en igual de
texas volvieron a sus clases en el
fatídico 24 de mayo un hombre armado
entró a la escuela primaria rock y
disparó a 19 niños y dos maestras el
colegio permanece cerrado y tal vez sea
demolido algunos de sus antiguos alumnos
fueron transferidos aquí a la escuela
primaria de walt de la tragedia no se
borra de sus memorias pero con banderas
coloridas y camisetas en las que se lee
juntos nos levantamos y juntos somos
mejores las maestras intentan ayudar a
sus estudiantes en un nuevo inicio
escolar mientras tratan de darle
tranquilidad a los padres que dejan a
sus hijos sea lo que mi hija estaba
pensando estaba asustada sé que estaba
asustada
aunque las clases comenzaron hace
semanas en algunas partes de texas los
funcionarios del distrito retrasaron el
inicio escolar en balde y pese a que el
departamento de seguridad pública del
estado se comprometió a poner casi tres
docenas de policías en el campus más
cámaras en la instalación de una cerca
de metal de 2,4 metros de altura por lo
menos 100 familias del pueblo
inscribieron a sus hijos en la escuela
virtual mientras que otras los cambiaron
a escuelas privadas yo estaba asustada
asustada de no recuperarlo pero hicimos
simulacros todo el verano le enseñé que
si escucha algo en el pasillo ya sabes
sal por la ventana corre no te detengas
no grites ahora los niños tienen
teléfonos cada uno de ellos no creía que
los niños de esa edad deberían tener
teléfonos pero ahora debe ser así
después de la masacre
376 oficiales recibieron un informe
condenatorio de un comité de la cámara
de representantes de texas por haber
esperado más de una hora antes de
confrontar al tirador decenas de
personas marcharon en contra del porte
de armas y washington aprobó la primera
gran ley bipartidista sobre violencia
armada en décadas